why would any retailer say we're not
joining up okay so this is a great story
first of all and what's happening
basically is that there is this war sort
of brewing in the mobile payments
business and on the one hand you've got
apple and all of the credit card
companies and they are all together
backing apple pay and on the other hand
you have all the retailers this effort
sort of being spearheaded by walmart but
includes walmart best buy target
rite aid cvs and they're backing
something called currency so what
happened was when apple pay came out
they said hundreds of thousands of
retailers across the country can accept
apple pay that is because any pos any
point of sale uh system that has near
field technology could actually accept
apple pay the moment they went live by
the way they could also accept a google
wallet and soft card what happened over
the weekend was that cvs and write it
because they didn't want everybody to
get comfortable using apple pay actually
turned off their near field
communication and at the same time
blocking not just apple pay but google
wallet and soft card wow
yeah it is so why are they doing this
what's the problem here okay so the
retailers want to cut out the credit
card companies all together because uh
they're annoyed that they pay about two
percent of all transaction costs to the
visa american express and mastercard the
other reason is data because if they can
actually market directly to the
customers what they're going to be able
to do is get more transaction data
they're going to be able to offer
discounts directly plus they're going to
be able to run their loyalty programs
directly to consumer apple pay of course
is promising users anonymity and they're
basically as you say banding together
right so they've got this this their own
system going on it's called currency
okay and how does it work it's a little
bit different it's through those quick
response codes so you know those uh sort
of barcode looking devices where you put
your phone over and it scans it that's
how it works it's different from the
near field communication technology
again this is so that the currency
merchants can have more information
about their users
it's not available though until 2015. so
that's where all the backlash we've seen
on social media comes uh it's a bold
move for rite aid and cvs to come out
and say we're not going to make it
easier for customers who want to pay
with apple pay you have to hold out for
us to roll out our own proprietary
system
all right olivia thank you so much and
until 2015 right i mean that is a while
okay olivia stearns on apple pay